Sierra Leone's main opposition leader
cast his ballot hopeful it could lead to
regime change
he is unimpressed by the Electoral
Commission
his party accuses it of buyers
are foreign
this is the man he wants to replace
incumbent president Julius Malibu who
beat him in the election five years ago
after casting his ballot the president
is happy with the conduct of the vote
every process can get glitches
[Music]
then not be ready you know open at seven
that not means anybody for go home
because we don't prepare for this day
for a very long time
there are 11 other candidates in the
presidential election but Bill and
Kamara are considered Front Runners
voting did not start on time in many
areas leading to an angry response from
voters
but first time voter aminator davo is
excited about the opportunity she hopes
her vote will help bring change
I voted for a person I like and I think
will bring changes in Sierra Leone right
now things are difficult
campaigning has been marked by violence
and intimidation but for many the
biggest concern is the threat of
post-election violence
11 years the economy and unemployment
are two most important issues on the
minds of Voters in this election Sierra
leoneans want a quick fix to inflation
and lack of jobs in addition whoever
wins this election will need to unite
the country after a bitterly fought
election
a candidate needs 55 percent of the
total votes to win outright otherwise a
second round must hold two weeks after
the results are declared the winner will
be sworn in two weeks later
Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera Freetown